[Musique]
il s'était déjà implanté dans les
jardins de la chapelle à clairefontaine
l'été dernier le restaurant éphémère de
sylvain régnier est de retour il s'est
installé dans le verger de la maison
triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines le concept est
toujours le même posait ses cuisines
dans un lieu convivial pour une courte
durée on avait bien aimé le concept
l'année dernière c'est pas mal
fonctionné et on se dit que ce serait
dommage de pas réitérer surtout que
cette année on est dans un lieu encore
plus vivant avec plus de monde avec un
espace couvert quand il pleut ouvert du
jeudi au lundi le restaurant propose
cette fois-ci une cuisine asiatique
tapas maison cuisine au wok name et bien
sûr traditionnel pas de taille c'est la
toute nouvelle cuisinière thaïlandaise
cob qui assure derrière les fourneaux
pour la saison mais péter a pour moi
même la platière pour les clients quoi à
ton mona même nombre d'armes au mythique
s'appelait pas mal parce qu'il n'y a pas
trop de restaurants thaï dans le coin
c'est vraiment une cuisine authentique
comme on mange en famille en thaïlande
et c'est très très épicée c'est très
savoureux et puisse aider on a de plat
familial le pad thaï qui a un plat très
populaire en asie elle fait un super
poulet aigre-douce à la récupérer la
recette d'un restaurant étoilé en
thaïlande un qualité de la cuisine est
remarquable
l'atmosphère aussi on aime beaucoup que
ce soit à l'extérieur autre nouveauté
cette année la proximité avec la maison
triolet aragon les clients de l'éphémère
peuvent bénéficier d'un tarif
préférentiel sur la visite on est allé
voir le musée qu'on n'avait pas encore
visité donc c'est un atout
supplémentaire
tous les environs c'est formidable et
puis nous connaissons bien la maison ça
fait une visite que vous pouvez rajouter
ça a énormément de charme et d'intérêts
des soirées musicales sont également
prévues tout au long de la saison le
restaurant est ouvert jusqu'au 30
septembre et affiche souvent complet la
réservation est conseillée pour les
soirs où les week ends